foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today is a cosmic queries Edition and we
titled this one sounds of the universe
sounds of the universe and there's only
one person
who is editor-in-chief of the sounds of
the universe and that's Kim Arcane we'll
get to her in just a moment let me
introduce my co-host Matt Kirsch and
Matt welcome back to start talk oh it's
a pleasure thanks for having me as
always yeah yeah host uh probably
science that's right just all around
funny guy we love you when you when you
come on so thanks for I I love being on
also I've uh I've recently just had a
couple of messages I'm on a tour at the
moment and just had a few tweets from
people who are like I didn't know you
were on this show I know you're from
Star Talk oh excellent oh my gosh
excellent excellent that's not it's
supposed to work you know exactly so hey
Star Talk listeners who've just seen me
on stage it's nice to see through the
screen
we have kimarkhand as our expert guest
she's been a stark talk visitor before
many years ago
pre-covered be before covert BC I think
we should call it that right yep she's a
visualization scientist and was an
engineering Tech lead for the child
Tundra x-ray Observatory a very
important space Observatory on the ranks
of Hubble except its data was in x-rays
so it didn't quite get all the pr that
Hubble got but it was one of our great
observatories that we put into orbit
around the Earth to see the universe in
X-rays and she works on several projects
uh we're interested in the stuff she's
done that connects the acoustic world to
the cosmic universe and some of the
stuff she's done has even went viral and
so so Kim welcome back to Star Talk
thanks it's so great to be back so what
is NASA's sonification project
well the sonification project
essentially is just a way that turns
NASA data into sound that's all it is
it's like data storytelling but using
our ears to to hear instead of just our
eyes to see it it actually started as a
project because during the pandemic I
really wanted to be able to keep working
with my community members and colleagues
who are blind or low vision and our
previous 3D printing program just became
very challenging during the pandemic you
couldn't be in the same room with
someone never mind share a 3D print and
so we started converting data into sound
and it turned into a much bigger thing
than I expected so this is not just for
for grins this is because it really can
serve the the needs and the desires of
the seeing impaired I mean that's yes I
mean it's not just oh that's cool no
it's like oh my gosh how else are you
gonna how else are you gonna feel this
yeah absolutely we had like I said been
working in 3D printing primarily so
translating data sets into three
dimensions that we could 3D print whole
or into tactile plates where you could
kind of create like relief maps from the
data but then during the pandemic that
was just all kind of impossible so I
recalled a call like that had met at a
visualization conference Matt Ruth so
he's part of system sounds and he and
his partner Andrew santiglida had been
working in some cool areas of data
sonification that I thought would be
great to bring towards the chander data
and so we started working together and
we created a few certifications and they
were very well received and I think I
was very surprised at that I thought it
would be you know something we created
for and with people who are blind or low
vision so I I don't know why I just
didn't expect it to go beyond that
Community but it really did and it was
it was very lovely to to witness that so
Matt I got an idea for her you want to
hear me you want to hear my new idea I'm
listening it started out with 3D
printing right so that's your sense of
touch if you otherwise don't have a
sense of sight
all right and then covid put a kibosh on
that and they switched senses because
you got we got five traditional ones
right so why why get stuck on one so
then you went to auditory data and I'm
thinking why not go to taste
I'd stop there like just
data yeah I don't know I feel like the
taste and the smells might be scary like
sulfur iron I don't know if I want any
of that yeah rotten eggs no thank you
so yeah hydrogen sulfide in the universe
and yeah oh my gosh this is a next the
next thing okay no I think we're good so
so just so I can get a grasp on this
because I think I obviously this is
Neil's world but this is this is
you can you've got a map or you've got
these you've you've got these images
that are coming through that are X-rays
or radio waves or whatever and you're
converting them into sound waves
directly so yeah what is happening right
so all this data that we're capturing
say the Tinder that's all all x-ray
lights so nothing that humans can
naturally see right so humans do this
amazing stuff where they build these
crazy spacecraft that can capture that
data and then write this awesome
software that can translate that data
because essentially astronomy like that
is just numerical right so we're
Translating that into something we can
see that that visual representation of
the object and then from there the
pipeline is to sound so we essentially
take all of those pixels that we get
from that resulting image and we do a
mathematical mapping from those pixels
into something we can hear by using like
assigning different kinds of sounds
either a synthetic sound or like an
instrumental sound for example so the
whole picture though is seen all at once
whereas sound has a beginning middle and
an end so yeah are you scanning left to
right right across the image and then it
comes into quote auditory view if I can
borrow that word yeah and then that's a
great question is that how you do that
yeah and that's and that's question
because it actually brings up some
interesting things of why this has been
such a fun project so it depends on the
data set is the short answer to your
question if it's a sort of landscape
shaped image if you will then we'll scan
from left to right if it's like tall and
skinny then we usually scan either top
to bottom or bottom to top depending if
we're trying to use stereo sound or
whatever the data is showing if it's an
object like a supernova Remnant that's
got very sort of spherical structure
then we typically do Center out or
radial scan right so we let the Data
Drive the process they're all it's a
bespoke process still at this point but
it's really taking the science that's
all tucked up inside those images and
letting that drive the data sonification
that makes how important it makes sense
now of course
yeah if you have a spherically symmetric
object you want to sample that in a
spherically symmetric
you want to match your geometry to the
geometry of what it is you're you're
presenting but now I got a bone to pick
with you yeah okay well Matt I need I
need backup on this okay in case she
gives me a hard time here you ready okay
yep
you are leaving people with the
impression that these objects in space
yes I see where you're going with this
so yes and no okay but I know I know no
I know because I saw the movie that in
space no one can hear you scream yeah I
saw alien that's how I knew I didn't
know before then of course
it was such a good movie so this is this
is why Rockets don't have car horns
get out of the way
so
is there some
uh what's the term uh is there some
housekeeping you have to do at the end
of all of this to say we're not actually
hearing the universe yes so I have two
answers to that and the simple one is
yes we we always say we're not holding a
microphone up to the sky right we're not
we're not recording actual sounds we're
too far away from any of these objects
even if they were making sounds however
there are objects in the universe that
do create sound waves and so one of the
simulations I think we're going to
listen to on this show today is actually
more Clips yes I want to make sure we
have some clips yes I will totally
before we get by the way this is a
cosmic query so we're just lay in some
some landscape here
in our garden in the garden yes yes yeah
so yeah there there is this idea that
there is no sound in space but that's
not really true you know there are sound
waves that are occurring in things like
um Galaxy clusters where there is all
this super hot gas around things like
supermassive black holes and a
supermassive black hole might have like
like say a relativistic jet coming out
of it and if that's surrounded by all of
that super hot gas the jet is kind of
like the drumstick and the hot gas is
like the drum right and it can create
sound waves so we do have an example
where we've taken a sound wave and
resonified up to something we can hear
okay Dan why did you you just convince
me I didn't want to be convinced I
wanted to argue with you about this
no she's right oh my gosh okay what
you're saying is wherever there's gas in
the universe which is in many places
it's it's reasonable to say what is
sound doing in that gas because the
sound is moving through a medium it's
the vacuum of Intergalactic space or or
wherever there is no gas that brings in
the the exactly that's that's where you
have the issue and we're not going to
hear anything here on Earth we're too
far and these sounds are way too deep in
all of that but out there in outer space
there are places where there are sound
waves occurring and even
um like the early unit verse you know
the the sort of that early
archaeological history if you will you
know like the cosmic microwave
background like when there was all of
that you know dense hot fog they can
translate that information into sound
and kind of learn about things authentic
sound not just not just right right I
know it's like version yeah I know audio
gear heads are always like trying to
search for like the deeper bases like
the bigger and bigger subwoofers like
hell
how deep are these Galaxy clusters
getting like what's mounted on the back
of someone's Volkswagen Golf like how
so I can wait Matt I'll ask that
question ready okay
Kim
you do have the perfect voice for that
question
how deep can you go
so for example the Perseus Galaxy
cluster which is like a couple hundred
million light years away from us so
pretty far
um that black hole is singing out at a
note that's I'm sorry my cat's saying
hello I'm singing out at a note that's
about 57 octaves below middle C
um and so that is I think one of the
deepest it's possible that m87 is also
deeper but it doesn't sing as well so
hold on let me just move my cat so my
microphone's not getting messed up
um but so that is as far as we are aware
at least one of the deepest notes in the
universe 57 octas below middle C B flat
okay so all these notes even those that
are not the deepest still fall well
outside of our 20 to 20 000 Hertz you
know auditory range so in order to hear
these sounds you have to
I don't say fake it but you have to
boost it change you have to put it in
another octave where we can hear it you
got it exactly okay yeah exactly so in
the sonification project for that we
recentified it by bringing back up about
57 and 58 octaves so that we can hear it
I'd like to recentify you got your own
vocabulary yeah we kind of have
developed it and I have to give such
credit to my partner it's not Andrew on
this project because we really thought
hard about this stuff and okay and
they've definitely tried to lay a lot of
groundwork it's it's a very exciting
thing so what's so what's the first clip
you have the first oh I think the
general sort of introduction to what
sonocation is and this is just
translating an image into sounds there's
no sound waves that we're capturing here
although this is a supermassive black
hole so there could be some
um but this is the inner like 400 Light
Years Around Sagittarius A star our
supermassive black hole at the center of
the Milky Way and what's cool about this
data set is we've got three different
kinds of light we've got light from the
Hubble Space Telescope that's kind of
like Optical near infrared we've got
Spitzer Space Telescope infrared data
and then we've got the Chandra data in
x-ray right and so all three of those
layers combined it makes a beautiful
image it's red yellow and blue
respectively from low to high energies
and it's very rich but very dense so you
know the the area around our
supermassive black hole it's like it's
like Times Square right there's a lot
going on it is it is the downtown of our
Milky Way region there's just a lot
happening there's all kinds of exploding
Stars large Stars lots of gas and dust
really cool stuff starts getting eaten
probably as far as getting eaten
asteroids getting snacks on all sorts of
great stuff right yeah yeah so the image
itself is very busy and dense and when
we listen to it what we've done is we've
assigned each of the types of light a
different sound and so the lowest energy
is a very soft piano the medium energy
from Hubble that's like a Plucky violin
and then the highest energy from Chandra
that's like this you know pringly little
Glockenspiel sound and so so we're
scanning across the image from left to
right wait a minute you get to pick your
own instruments we do yes who
start instrument in Chief person who who
we did we self-selected I guess yeah and
I should say I should say to be fair I'm
a former band and chorus geek so I have
some music sort of theory under my back
um also Matt is actually a musician
today like he plays in a band
um and he's also an astrophysicist and
then Andrew is like an amazing musician
and sound engineer too okay
a nice mixture I won't yeah exactly so
okay we're self-selected but it seems to
me you could choose instruments
differently so that the center of the
the center of the Galaxy feels kind of
bluesy or absolutely or hard rock you
know or or country right whistling sound
like exactly right yeah that might okay
Matt what do you say a kazoo yeah yeah
and a slide whistle I once said whistle
and an accordion yeah yeah yeah
but yeah sure what do you want your
Universe to sound like that is that is a
question because we are absolutely
picking instruments based on the science
story that's in that data that we're
trying to communicate right
um so we want the three layers to be
distinct from each other because that's
one of the the key things particularly
for people who are blind or low vision
they're accessing this data with their
ears they want to be able to hear all of
that amazing sciency goodness tucked
inside so Kim it seems to me you have
more information than just the sound if
you can listen to it in Stereo correct
correct exactly you can get a sense of
that positional information and also
what that helps do I think is make you
sort of feel immersed in it right and I
think that is sort of the gift of
presenting in this more musical sound
based way you have that sort of gift of
time across but also that immersive sort
of opening to it okay let's do it in
Stereo the center of the Galaxy go for
it
[Music]
foreign
okay so the black hole in the center of
the Galaxy really fed that experience
but what about m87 that's one of the
largest known galaxies in the universe
trillions of stars it's got a Mondo
black hole in its Center one of the
biggest known it's got Jets and you tell
me you you worked on that one as well
yes we did actually create a
certification of the m87 II because
that's another system that is supposedly
also burping out into the surrounding
gas and from what I understand the note
might actually be pretty low like 59
octaves below middle C but that
sonification is a little bit simpler
than the one that we just heard it's
more of a basic sound scrubbing across
left to right mostly the jet features
that you're seeing in different kinds of
light so you've isolated the jet to
listen to rather than all the downtown
Times Square Behavior going on in our
own correct yeah got it got it let's
take a listen for that thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
cool so what octave did you put it in
um that one I don't actually know what
the octave is I could go look it up
really quick but it would be acceptable
that one was yeah that one was not
um so we don't have the sound waves
captured for m87 like we do for Perseus
so that one was just a scan of the jet
data in three different kinds of lights
that one was a little bit different got
it got understood understood and so uh
and we have a third and final bit but
this is just a sampling of what is in
your full portfolio so we have the
Chandra Deep Field
so what are we listening for here this
is one of my favorites because if you've
ever seen the image it's not the most
exciting perhaps it looks like you've
taken a black canvas and just splattered
some multi-colored paint droplets on it
right but the science of that data set
is really important it's the deepest
x-ray image we've ever taken Chandra
looked at a patch of the sky for a
really long time I want to say it was
about 40 days and 40 nights very poetic
sounding and captured like this this
landscape if you will of black holes so
thousands of black holes or very bright
galaxies with supermassive black holes
at their cores and if you look at the
image
it doesn't always communicate that as
easily right to a non-expert but when we
sonified it this is using stereo sound
again we scrolled from the bottom of the
image to the top the image itself the
X-ray sources they are shown by energy
levels the lowest energy sources in
x-ray are red up to the highest energy
x-ray in blue and we can play with that
so the sounds are synthesized sounds and
you can hear the different energies of
those x-rays as you scan you're telling
me your acoustic map is better than the
original data that's what it's actually
you're bragging capture that a little
bit a little bit it captures more of
that science fancy goodness that I think
the image actually can which was a
really cool project and also when you're
orbiting Earth you have to be careful
what you mean when you say 40 days and
40 nights yes indeed so chander goes
about a third of the way to the moon so
it has a really lovely view of the
universe and the engineers had to work
pretty hard to make sure Chandra would
be able to capture all of that data
across time it wasn't a steady 40 days
of 40 nights straight yeah yeah all
right so let's give it a listen
[Music]
foreign
so Kim this has been a delightful
segment when we come back we're going to
pick up our Cosmic queries theme with
questions given to us from our patreon
membership sounds great StarTalk returns
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
Edition we're talking about sonifying
the universe oh my gosh and we've got
the one of the world's experts on that
very topic Kim arkan again Kim welcome
back to Star Talk
and I got with me my co-host Matt
kirshan and so Matt you brought
questions with you I I do yeah and uh
I'll try and get through as many of
these patreon uh Patron questions as I
can okay this is some really great ones
um some some things you've already
started to answer so Malcolm uh my fan
from Trinidad and Tobago you you've
already answered the first part of his
question but he also asked how do you
and your team decide which areas of the
universe to study and what factors go
into making those decisions well that's
a great question yeah it's a big
universe it is a big universe you're
cherry picking it right it's a big
universe out there so first I guess what
Chandra looks at is decided by a
committee of scientists right so anybody
can propose for a Time on Chandra and
those proposals are all put together and
then like sorted through and decided on
what channel will actually look like and
then time is you know set to it and
chandra's schedule is created and all
that happened so then when it comes to
us to actually choose what we saw Fi
we're looking for objects that will
sonify well if that makes sense so we're
looking for things that will give us
like a really nice landscape of
something like the galactic center that
we talked about earlier a way to really
get all of that really interesting
science material translate into sound or
we're looking at something like an
exploded star that has a lot of detail
in it that as you're like scanning
across it like a you know like a radar
scan if you will really lets you get a
sample for what that object is like so
we're definitely cherry picking through
the universe because this is more of a
bespoke project it's not an automated
project that you can just scan
everything with the push of a button but
what it does is it absolutely enables
our our friends and and colleagues who
are blind or low vision to be able to
sample some of the most iconic and
important data sets that we've got in
our back pocket so it's interesting
because we or we make a selection
at any time for for what we want to know
about first and second and third so what
you're doing is no different from that
you're finding the the the parts of the
universe that would be most interesting
yeah exactly yeah some of those really
cool stories that need to be told
through sound
and earlier you were talking about 3D
printing you have a book that just came
out yes
stars in your hand the guide to 3D
printing the cosmos yeah that sounds a
little scary you know you don't want
people printing black holes it's true
it's true though I actually do have a 3D
print of a black hole with me today but
indeed indeed it's just it's the little
guy right here oh okay cool but yeah
it's it's a thank you for asking about
the book it's fun I I like writing I've
been writing with my partner Megan
Watsky for a while because I don't know
I just I love books
um and I know other people do as well
and and this book was just kind of so
old-fashioned of you I know it is
over like Tick Tock any day books don't
even require batteries I mean what's
wrong with you you know I know I'm very
old-fashioned vintage I think they call
it now okay right that's what they use
but yeah I I love books and so for me it
was a great way to concatenate all of
these cool 3D printable data sets of our
Cosmos into one place
um it's just like a quick guide if you
will to some of the the cool sites to
feel I guess versus the sights to see so
things like exploding Stars galaxies
some constellations
um I worked with a bunch of colleagues
around the world and gathered a bunch of
data sets into one place okay excellent
and and it's out now it is it's out now
and it's meant to be a very gentle
introduction so even if you don't have a
ton of experience with 3D printing or
with the universe it's it's a very
gentle sort of workbook style feel to it
to kind of
give you a little intro congratulations
on that yes thanks yeah so what else you
got for us Matt so I like I like this
question a lot this is from Terina from
San Francisco who says I work with
visually impaired people and we use lots
of technology using sound waves to
detect obstacles beeping gets louder
when the device gets closer to the
object for example uh does the same
thing happen in space or do we need an
atmosphere for this do radio waves
bounce off objects is that one way to
measure and or detect unseen objects oh
that's an interesting one Neil do you
want to take that one well I note so it
turns out they're not many telescopes in
the world that have that dual capability
we had one it was the Arecibo telescope
which collapsed out of misuse but it was
a huge radio telescope that can receive
radio waves but can can also transmit
and so it's the transmitting that allows
you to beam it at a at a thing that you
can't otherwise detect
and record the signal that comes back to
you and make a map of it so this is like
sonar like a like a battery precisely
it's sonar but not with sound it's like
sonar but with radio waves I guess they
call it radar
radio detection
let's say that's a that's a cool acronym
right there so for many asteroids that
are just so small that a regular
telescope can't really reveal what their
surface looks like then you have these
radio wave
um topography topographic maps that you
can create with them so so in a way
technically you can measure how fast
they're going give them a speeding
ticket because that's what your the cops
do with their radar gun using microwaves
they beam microwaves at you and time the
signal as it returns and invoke the
speed of light and they get exactly how
fast you're moving so there are things
you can determine about these objects
but only in our solar system far away
it'll take years for the signal to get
there
and by the time the signal comes back
you're not interested anymore
this idea of bouncing signals off of
things the best you can do is at the
speed of light and at distances in the
universe it's not a very practical
solution
for for ranged for getting the distances
to things or even for giving them
speeding tickets
I I had no idea traffic cops were
invoking the speed of light yeah faster
than I figured yes they are yes so Gavin
Bamberg this is sort of like the reverse
of what you're doing so Gavin Bamber
from North Vancouver says please visit
and my question might be Arcane for our
cans I see what you did there Gavin
very clever but Neil
uh maybe Neil and Matt can provide
assistance uh let's I don't think so I
think the Neil Parts but various
wavelengths of light can be explained to
a blind person in terms of varying
levels of heat but how can we translate
the sound of the universe for deaf
people to understand
so I guess this is sort of the reverse
of your converting signals into sound
how do we convert sounds into other
signals for deaf people yeah that's it
because yeah because because Kim you're
focusing on site impaired
yeah and what about the hearing impaired
well so for the most part what we're
doing is We're translating an image that
already exists into sound so for people
who are hearing impaired they do have
access to that original image but what
we also do is we provide like a
description of what the sonification is
so it gives a loose sense of what's
included in that translation but yes
things are going to be Lost in
Translation you can't really get the
essence of the feeling of music through
just words but we do add that as a layer
of accessibility to our products and I
would add if you have sight but not
hearing people with sight were not
saying to themselves gee I wish I could
hear the universe to understand it
better they would they can they can see
it right so right yes so this whole
project actually came about for two
things in a way so one all of the
certification work that I've ever done
has been inspired by my friend Wanda
Diaz she's an astronomer and a computer
scientist who's been blind since she was
a teenager and she uses sonification to
actually they study Stars she had her
whole PhD thesis kind of showed that
scientists humans can become better
listeners right and so that that has
always been kind of the Inspiration
Point um
I think everybody was a better listener
it would be a good thing yeah it's a
whole different world how did that
happen yeah yeah oh my gosh yes
especially today um but also my my
friend and colleague Christine Malik
she's been blind since birth and so
she's never seen the night sky she's
never seen any of these images and for
her she's remarked to me that these on
vacations they're they're like a main
meal where she gets her nutritional
um you know stuff from versus somebody
who's cited who can access the images
that the sound is like a dessert right
it's it's delicious and it's another
layer you like it
um but for her the main meal is adding
like the nutrition that she needs and I
love that way of thinking about it
because it does provide that you know
everybody has different access points
into stuff right so Kim this is personal
for you I mean you have close friends
very it's very personal for me honestly
and my so I'm like a super super shy
person and at least I've always been
super shy and when I was a kid I had a
very hard time making friends
um my very first friend in kindergarten
was a little girl who was partially deaf
and she like came up to me and she made
me her friend and she like her helper
started teaching me sign language and
all these things and you know that's
something that I have never I know it
sounds corny I know it does but that is
something that like I've never forgotten
like I've never forgotten and that
someone helped me in those early days
when I could like barely move from
behind my mother right and so I don't
know there's just this part of me that
like wants to look at the world like
that do you know what I mean corny but
there we are no it opens up a box that
we don't even know we're in yeah
just how many potentially brilliant
scientists were kept away from the work
that they could be doing because it
wasn't as accessible to them and right
100 yeah if there's anything that I hope
comes out of this project it's that it's
that I hope other people can sort of see
themselves or picture themselves
Envision themselves hope for themselves
to be scientists or just part of the
science Community you know that's just
part of the inclusion movement really I
mean if you want to think of it more
holistically yeah than that yeah yeah
all right Matt give me some more all
right so Connor home uh from squim
Washington with his pronunciation guide
I appreciate that Connor that's a place
in Washington it spells s-e-q-u-i-n
but then there is a pronunciation in in
Brackets afterwards I'm glad because
all right cool never knew but Conor says
really love the show what is the most
active electromagnetic wavelength in the
universe also also are all wavelengths
found everywhere in the universe that's
a great question I mean I nearly I'm
sure I have better answers for these
things because I love the way your mind
works but you know the more energetic
you get obviously it's going to be very
very active so that's how I'm thinking
of active so I would say things like
gamma rays and x-rays are going to be
the most energetic regions of the
universe and hence the most active sort
of but there are less x-ray photons in
the universe overall so maybe that's not
the perfect sort of way to think about
things I'd like that I don't know I like
that distinction you're making yes so
there are places that have very high
energy output all right in in X-rays and
gamma rays those are the highest energy
variants of of photons of light but
if you're in another place where it's
giving out mostly infrared but boatloads
of infrared right then the total energy
budget might be higher there than where
your single high energy photons might be
found so that's an excellent distinction
to make but the whole electromagnetic
spectrum as we as we've discussed in a
star talk explainers before it's a full
range you go from radio waves microwaves
infrared visible light red orange yellow
green blue violet ultraviolet x-ray
X-rays and gamma rays and that sequence
is a sequence from low energy to high
energy and not all parts of the universe
give equal amounts of those bands
and in fact we didn't know
that the Universe was talking to us in
bands outside of visible light until we
discovered invisible light
and they'd say well wait a minute
you know our eyes aren't every I mean
think about if you're religious you know
why would God give you eyes that can't
see everything you want to see right the
people had to like figure this out what
does it mean that there's stuff going on
that our our bio physiology has no
access to and so it took the methods and
tools of science to discover ways to to
discover and detect and figure out ways
to detect infrared ultraviolet x-rays
Gamers and we've exploited them all in
our modern civilization which is a great
Triumph of 20th century physics I would
say but yeah so x-rays enabled us to see
black holes to discover the vicinity of
black holes gamma rays we found bursts
of gamma rays in the universe we didn't
know they were there
infrared we find deep gas clouds that
are birthing Stars each of these bands
is a different
is a different window
to this universe in which we're immersed
and so yeah and now Kim with what you're
doing you're opening up Windows of
access to those windows uh that are
otherwise invisible right so yeah that's
the cues back to what our discussion is
so well right because what are we doing
when we're studying x-ray astronomy
we're transcending human Vision right
yes and so then that we can take the
data and translate it into some other
way of knowing some other way of making
meaning through sound or yeah perhaps
taste or sense that I still yeah
um you know but I'm waiting for that you
call me okay I am I mean I've read comic
strips I know smell has waves yeah it's
uh you know I'm kind of picturing those
like 1980s 1990s like scratch and
stickers
is that what's in my future is that what
you're saying I don't know I don't think
so it's next it's next Matt let's slip
in one more question before we take it
okay well this is this is are connected
and by the way this is I'm filling in
for Chuck and this this patreon Patron
says Chuck you're the only person to
pronounce my last name correctly on
first attempt so let's give this a go
we'll go tell Chuck that we'll talk
let's give this a go I'm gonna go with
Colby laprazy from South Carolina sorry
if it's laprisi or or anything else but
says I'm wondering why a pulsar is best
seen in X-ray and radio wave seems
contrary thanks love the show okay cool
in fact we're gonna take a break and
we're gonna come back to that very
question
X-rays and radio waves they do seem
contradictory uh we're here with the
world's expert on sonifying the universe
when we come back
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
but Matt what do we call this Edition
sonifying the universe not personifying
it but sonifying sonifying let's get
this thing generally solidifying not
just for you it's for everyone yeah yeah
that's right not personifying sonifying
the universe is for everyone Kim arkhan
Delight delighted to have you back as
our guest on this fascinating subject
that we're learning that it goes deep
with you not only personally in your
life experience but as a child but with
friendships that you've carried
throughout your life uh so we left off
Matt read that question one more time
yeah why is a pulsar best seen in X-ray
and radio wave seems country
hmm well I mean I can add that you know
pulsars are really fascinating objects
because they're like the leftover cores
of stars that have passed on exploded if
you will exploded their guts out all
over the universe and so all of that
that material that's packed in there
it's super heated it's super exciting
great for x-rays
um but it is always interesting to me
how well
x-ray information and radio information
do complement each other not just for
things like pulsars for things like
galaxies things like Supernova remnants
and Neil I would love for you to talk to
us about that no this is great this is I
mean you it's a brilliant answer when
you have a place like a pulsar which is
extremely hot anytime you have very high
temperatures in the universe things
happen that give you high energy photons
so X-rays and occasionally gamma rays in
the most extreme case but also a pulsar
has a magnetic field
and a magnetic field when it interacts
with some of the particles in its
vicinity will generate radio waves and
so so for example Jupiter has a very
strong magnetic field and a strong radio
waves that emit that that it emits so in
fact Kim have you thought of
acoustically representing the planets
those that have sort of radio wave
emission yes or you just we just badass
things out in the far reaches of the
Universe I do I do like the higher
energy work I won't lie
um but so there is actually some really
cool data sonification work on some of
the planets that man Andrew have done at
system sounds and we are actually
working on some related stuff right now
yep okay yeah very good very good so the
no no part of the universe is is out of
your purview nope that's very good all
right so so pulsars gives you both ends
of the spectrum there because it's doing
more than one thing
and we have magnetic fields you tend to
have radio wave emissions and high
temperatures you'll get higher energy
light so that's all that's all that's
happening there it's not magic or
anything but it's a great question yeah
and they do complement them so well they
do indeed and it makes it for a more
interesting sonification projects yes
exactly yeah and we have actually
sonified The Crab Nebula Pulsar so that
might be one that your listener might
want to take a listen to that was the
very first Pulsar yeah the one in the
center of the crab net first known
gorgeous Pulsar gorgeous yeah in fact
there was giving us pulses and what else
can you think if nothing in the universe
ever gave you such regular signals such
reliable repeated signals and we were
sure it was Little Green Men I know it
did seem suspicious
unfortunately not fortunately yeah yeah
nature nature can do that it turns out
but had it been giving us digits of pi
then that's another thing right yeah
there's more reason to be worried
all right Matt keep going all right I'm
going to combine a couple because we've
got a lot to fit in but I still want to
hear that oh absolutely yeah so I'm
going to combine a couple because we've
got a lot to fit in So Daniel Johansson
wants to know what other wavelengths or
types of telescopes could bring us new
views on the universe in the future and
beer and Amin from Florida says if you
had to design any instrument to begin
answering more complex questions what
would be the ideal properties it would
have well let me lead off and then Kim
you pick up the Baton here so two a new
telescope that came online within the
last six years is ligo the laser
interferometer gravitational wave
Observatory it's just it's discovering
grab gravitational waves from colliding
black holes that have been moving
through the universe for billions of
years and that's so Kim that sounds like
a natural to turn that into sound yes
and actually I'm pretty sure that
someone has done that work and I forget
who it was but I am pretty sure
this is knee jumping I will take this
one guys okay great
but I see to remember on this on the
show when I when we're here with John 11
who is all about black holes and and
radio waves and I'm sorry gravitational
waves rather yes she played
an audio representation of two black
holes colliding which actually one of
our patreon patrons asks about this is
Troy from the DMV area I asked about
said it sounded like a drop of water and
does
does the universe sound like water
because of all the waves floating around
oh I remember because it was as the
black holes spiraled closer and closer
and more tightly they the way they
sonified it it was like
it was like a big thing attention a
listening class Matt in fact we have
that sound right now check it out
so Kim how'd they do
um I think they did pretty well though
I'm of course partial to our own
technique I think it's a really
interesting way to represent data and
anytime you can open up access like that
it's an absolutely worthy Endeavor so
yeah a plus okay excellent excellent and
another kind of telescope we don't quite
have yet we have detectors but not
really telescopes you can detect
something but not know anything about
the object you just know that you
detected something so that's the
difference between a telescope and just
a bare ass detector sitting out there uh
neutrinos
are are not light they're not
gravitational waves but it's another
thing in the universe moving through the
universe that comes from some places and
not others we have neutrino detectors
but not really neutrino telescopes so
that would be another Frontier that we
can put on the docket uh the day we have
a telescope uh Kim I want to see you
lined up right at the door right there
and if I could just add it's kind of a
chi but I also would love love to have
access to a Next Generation Chandra
Chandra is almost 25 years old that
celebrates 25 years next year and yeah
it it we could definitely use for like a
bigger more powerful version just just
tell Congress and get the 10 billion
dollars that's all ah right Sam's web
but in x-rays please could someone
deliver that that would be great oh yes
that's a helpful please reference point
yes
from Texas's question right there so I'm
going to jump on to Kenneth Von
smellsmore of the Atlanta Von smells
Moors who says Satan we all know the
Atlanta Von smells Morris of course Very
official
slate and here we go our senses will be
developed here on Earth using the
physics of our environment we know other
animals can sense other phenomena like
magnetic fields how might an extra
planetary being sensor communicate with
a four-dimensional space whale sing via
gamma rays could they feel via
gravitational waves wow I love that Kim
Kim
and how much effort do you put in to
thinking about alien sensory systems
none or are you boxed into being here
yeah so I was always proud of ourselves
for like transcending human Vision but
are you just called you just got called
out yeah you just got busted I feel so
boring and vanilla right now after that
question that's pretty intense
yeah it's so I I can address that that's
I can't answer it but I can toss some
words in that direction and I can say
that in science we've known maybe for
300 years that our five senses are not
telling us everything that's out there
and when we first discovered infrared
we said well could there be even more
than infrared and then that's how we
start filling out
our ability to know the world in which
we're immersed I can say without
hesitation that the methods and tools of
science have developed at least a dozen
senses right whether it could be
magnetic fields gravitational vectoring
the uh polarization of light these are
things you cannot see
you cannot experience we don't have the
means of experiencing it but our methods
and tools of science can
so I say to myself
if an alien has extra senses why
wouldn't they just be drawn from what we
already know we can determine
by science just because our physiology
doesn't get it our science can
which means when someone walks out and
Kim I don't know if you feel this
someone says you know I have a sixth
sense and I say I'm not impressed I have
12 senses
coming to my lab you'll see every sense
that we've got so
um yeah it would be fun to just think
about just broaden what it is you've
done yes a lot to be proud of but maybe
that's just the beginning that's it I
love when people think big right and I
love when you're thinking outside of the
box because you know even with this
project there are people that were sort
of like doubting is adding sound really
worth it or with 3D printing is like
that really necessary and each time
we've tried one of these projects that
just goes a little bit you know into a
strangely new place we we keep getting
rewarded for it so yeah thinking
thinking creatively thinking big it's I
don't know it's really worth it it
really is love it love it all right Matt
give me some more three minutes what can
we do in three minutes uh-oh we can
speak through a few anthropos but we'll
see it we'll see how good came is with
sound bites that this is oh I'm very bad
with short answers this is your this is
your next okay go ahead um Dylan from
San Diego says how is the information
carried by X-rays and other
electromagnetism different from
information carried by mechanical waves
like sound that's a great question I
don't that's too physicsy for me no it's
no light is just photons yeah just
photons and this there's the good Photon
joke you ready Photon checks into a
hotel
and the bellhop says do you have any
luggage and the photon says no I'm
traveling light thank you that is really
cool that's even safe for elementary
school so yeah so it is a
self-propagating way which was an
amazing Discovery when it was made in
the late 1800s and sound is energy
pulsing through a medium and yeah this
is this is the issue about sound getting
to us through the vacuum of space which
it can't what Joey Santos also asks is
is there any medium that sound can
potentially travel through in space like
dust cloud or trap particles which I
think use answered a bit in the area
around black holes but yes absolutely
yeah any of that exactly exactly and
there's two particles around Stars
anything this is her Total Fitness yes
yep that's your that's your palette yes
yes I love it Sam Pennington uh from
Texas says I've been listening to audio
files that say this is what Jupiter
sounds like is that really what Jupiter
sounds like or is that a compression of
the spectrum into audio form
so I don't know what he's listening to
or what that person is listening to but
I know there is um a scientist Bill
Kurth I think his name is that does a
lot of interesting stuff with planetary
data he's using things like radio
admissions of auroras from Saturn it
props perhaps from Jupiter to plasma
oscillations
so Saturn has Aurora Borealis just the
way we do yeah you just blew through
that oh sorry well I'm just trying to
get through it
that is true I did help rush you and you
and you're fulfilling the Mandate and I
am stopping that okay yeah Earth is not
the only planet in town with the
northern lights and the Southern Lights
that's good to know because it's
expensive to get to Iceland right now so
that's it if you have uh a magnetic
field as we do in an atmosphere and the
sun has its charged particles it'll
render your atmosphere glow and that
itself generates radio waves so just
that's where you just blew right past
that again but there are great
sonications of those so it's it's
possible that that's what they've
listened to that's that's a guess at
least it's possible that that's what
they listen to Edwin Florence from West
Lynn Oregon says uh since the James Webb
has provided very fascinating data from
the infrared part of the spectrum what
data do you hypothesize the Chandra
project will provide from the shortest
wavelengths of the spectrum so I think
well Candor has been providing fantastic
data of things like exploding Stars
things like colliding galaxies merging
black holes pulsars you name it I mean
you find a lot of X-ray data more than I
ever would have expected and what's
actually pretty cool about it is Chandra
data and web data complement each other
very very well
um so we have we're actually in the
process of working on a signification
right now that combines James Webb data
and chander data of the Stefan's quintet
um and actually I think that should be
out in like another week or so
um is one of the first images released
by the James Webb Telescope exactly the
five Galaxy interaction and there's like
these beautiful Pockets where the X-ray
data just kind of fills in like a bridge
in between some of those interacting
galaxies and it's it's a really lovely
way to experience the data so yes more
on that soon again you say this casually
but I want to emphasize that when you
have two completely different telescopes
observing the same object
they're going to reveal different things
to you but maybe those two different
things connect in some way physically uh
in terms of what a phenomenon going on
inside and so uh this is extraordinary
Vision to bring to bear on these objects
when you have completely different
telescopes looking in the same direction
especially at the same time yep so it's
powerful very cool yeah all right Matt
she she's doing pretty good isn't she I
mean I'm trying
she's got the quick she's got the quick
answers go I like to answer Longs and
I've been slowing you down I've been
messing with you with your mojo here
okay one more question
we'll squeeze this in uh Bill Bailey
from Ohio says speaking of hearing the
universe will we know the difference
between the sounds or gravitational
waves created by the big bang and those
created by Ultra supermassive black
holes oh
so like more than just the cosmic wave
background kind of thing is that well no
no you know we're talking about the big
bang itself so like be responsible for
yeah even before the cosmic background
yeah it seems to me that'd be if we if
we do the calculation right
it should look different it's a
different phenomenon right you want to
blow the universe into existence it
seems to me that would have a different
signal signature from two colliding
black holes right right and would you
agree with that that would be great to
hear so yeah let's do it let's capture
yeah and what would that be that would
be like the ending bombastic finale to a
classical Symphony yes exactly exactly
and yes actually thanks for cueing that
because I can say one of the really
interesting like extensions of this
project has been whenever we talk about
sonifications there are musicians in the
audience and they want to play The
Sounds they want to play the data and so
we're actually working on that I'm
working with a young composer who's very
talented and she's transcribing
translating the sonifications into stuff
that's playable by humans with their
instruments so I think it's violins all
of that so I think for the Big Bang
everything what do we need has to be
playing simultaneously at its loudest
absolutely lots of percussions lots of
percussions I don't know I don't know
that is not the time to hold back all
right all right fine every instrument
ever known to humans bring it in at full
volume there's the big bang for you we
got it we don't even have to that might
be pretty cool yeah it would be totally
cool all right well Kimberly it's been
Delight to have you back this is your
second appearance on Star talk it's
great to check in with you and you have
this new book out
um 3D printing of the universe and the
original the full title is stars in your
hands
very very poetic thank you I think we
love it uh Matt thanks for being with us
here and and Kim where do we find you on
social media what's your footprint
um I'm on Twitter and Instagram I think
at Kimberly Powell for both and then I
can hit me on my way Kimberly Cowell
k-o-w-a-l it's from when I had my maiden
name a long time ago oh
and then my website is kimarkand.com
kimarkand.com all right we can totally
find you that way all right all right I
think so again thanks for being on Star
Talk Matt always good to have you here
man always good to be here all right
this has been Star Talk Cosmic queries
Edition what the universe sounds like to
us all but especially to Kim our cams
right until next time heal the grass
Tyson here
[Music]